[Music]
I think entrepreneurs have to always
think about relationships and keeping
those relationships and it doesn't have
to be a lot of work that's really what
matters relationships are everything
what's the habit that most entrepreneurs
are missing so Jason if your place is
burning down and you can take one thing
from your office what are you taking
with you welcome everybody to the modern
master show on this show I bring on
people who I want to learn from
entrepreneurs that I can pick their
brain and hopefully in that process I
get a little bit better as an
entrepreneur myself and you guys too
my guest today special guest named Jason
Harris he is the founder of a
advertising creative agency called
mechanism out of California he's twice
won the small agency of the Year award
he's got a new book out called the
soulful art of persuasion with 11
different habits that you can be more
persuasive with Jason there it is
welcome aboard man you can never promote
too hard I love it dude I love it so so
listen before we get started officially
with questions and everything since we
do this over Instagram it can be a
little personal so I'd love if you could
take us on a little quick tour of your
office oh sure
you got it I hope I don't have anything
we're scary here this is some artwork
David Bowie love David Bowie this is can
you see that it's me with the Joe Biden
yeah you may be president who knows I'm
a big Jets fan okay these are the checks
on that can you see that yeah
it's signed who's a sign body it's
signed by Joe Namath and all the Super
Bowl 3 legend legend I love Muhammad Ali
I don't know if you can see that yeah
you know I got a record player here play
a lot of music what's on the wall this
wall it's just this is just black oh
yeah yeah that's that's just wallpaper
cool I like it okay so so Jason if your
place is burning down and you can take
one thing from your office
what are you taking with you if my place
is burning down and I could take one
thing I'm gonna take this little pup all
right tell us the story says uh this is
just a I got this in a trip I took to
Miami with a good friend of mine and
it's it's a kootz
kind of knockoff and he brings me a lot
of joy it's a balloon dog and there's
really not a great story like it wasn't
about winning a piece of business or
some big milestone I had in my life but
just this thing makes me happy I can
brings joy to LA so so the name is sign
helmet is is burning to ashes and you're
taking the balloon dog get another
helmet but I love it so so talk to us
about persuasion what what do
entrepreneurs need to know to to tell
better stores to persuade better so that
people will buy their products will
follow them what do we need to know well
the idea behind you know I think
persuasion today has a bit of a dirty
connotation to it it sounds like you're
trying to get one over on someone it
sounds like you're trying to win someone
over at all costs and the soulful part
and principles that I talk about in the
book are there's four principles so I'll
just run through them real quick yeah
one is about being original so one
principle is about original and it's
about being unequivocally yourself
leaning into your quirks understanding
your belief system and who you are as a
person
never shying away from it it's never
about trying to mimic the other person
or follow those old rules of selling
which is you know try to try to act like
you have the same interest of someone
else it's about leaning into who you are
as a person and be yourself everyone
else is already taken so that's sort of
principle one principle two is about
generous and it's all about being a
generous person and never expecting
anything in return so it's about being
gem
with your time your connections your
energy your advice sometimes it's even
generous with a text or a message or a
gift
and so generosity is a principle that I
firmly believe in and the third one is
empathetic which is about understanding
your audience and trying to bring people
together and know that humans are we all
have the same desires and we're not it's
not about us versus them mentality and
the final one is soulful which is all
about developing skills and you don't
need a million skills in life you need
two or three that you're really really
good at and it's mirroring skill with
purpose we're trying to do good and give
back and those are basically the what I
mean by soulful persuasion and those all
come together by building long-term
relationships playing the long game as
an entrepreneur and in business and not
looking at things in short-term
transactional ways so I'm loading the
website here I see the four and then and
then you dive deeper you got eleven
breakdowns inside those four yeah the
habits to do what do you think
what's the habit that most entrepreneurs
are missing that they need to be doing
more up to be more persuasive I think
most entrepreneurs miss this habit which
I talk about is as never let your
relationships drop to zero and I think
as entrepreneurs and by the way it's not
that I'm a master at all of these habits
it's that I know that these habits are
what build long-term business success
and I call them habits because some of
us are born great storytellers some of
us are born naturally generous some
people are not naturally generous like
like me I had to learn that so it had to
become a habit and it's something that
you can practice and when you practice
these which I talked about in the book
they become habitual because you're
doing them it's like muscle memory
you're doing it over and over again but
the lesson that I would say on a lot of
entrepreneurs skip is this idea of never
let relationships drop to zero and what
happens as when you're working and
you're building a business as you tend
to focus on what's right in front of you
and you tend to focus on the can
actions and the people they can add the
most value to your business and you skip
over and you forget the friends and the
ex co-workers and the other business
associates that you perceive cannot add
value and when those relationships drop
and then it come you know someone takes
the job somewhere else and you want
something from them that's not the time
to reach out because they're gonna know
that you've let that relationship drop
and that all you want is a transaction
from them so I think entrepreneurs have
to always think about relationships and
keeping those relationships and it
doesn't have to be a lot of work it can
be a coffee or dinner a text and I'm
thinking about you but it's it's looking
at those relationships and always
keeping them alive in some form because
that's really what matters relationships
are everything so I am an introvert and
and have very low need for really you
have a live Instagram show where where
you're broadcasting you yet you uh you
you you call yourself an interview well
I ask you had to overcome well yeah I
mean and this is gonna do my youtube
channel we've got two million
subscribers and three hundred million
views on a channel but I think everybody
has purpose and my purpose is to help
entrepreneurs your purpose comes from
your pain and so I've had to overcome it
even before getting on this I'm nervous
you know what if he doesn't show up what
if nobody asks question what if you know
like all of the typical thoughts come
through my head but I still keep going
off and doing it as somebody though who
doesn't so after this you know naturally
I wouldn't I wouldn't reach out to you I
wouldn't be like what's going on are you
doing but well don't worry no but that's
why you're you know you're more
successful in in that department that I
am so so what should I do so I mean I've
had tons of guests on my show I've had
lots of connections of people who've who
are super successful entrepreneurs what
would you recommend I'm a systems guy
should I just put it in like hey anybody
who's been on my
every month find a way to bring value to
them yeah I would just say because
you've been able to cultivate these
relationships by having all these
Instagram live shows and so you have
this database in this network and so
what I would I put in like four people a
week I literally put in my calendar and
it's a 15-minute slot and I put those
names in and when I think about that
person pops up I'm like oh I know that
person was a queen fan and so I remember
reading that article about that Bohemian
Rhapsody movie that took a different
spin on it or uncovered something new
I'm just gonna send them a link on the
DMM a link or send them a text and all
it is is you're saying hey I'm thinking
about you right and I know what your
interests are it doesn't have to be some
exhaustive thing that your research but
it's it's just being a little like hey
I'm thinking about you and you're
important to me and you have that means
if you're not good at it or you don't
want to do it and you're not natural at
it plug it into your calendar and make
it part of your work stream and it's
super effective because all these people
that you've met if you just sort of let
them lapse and you don't keep up with
them
you know that that's a that's not great
as an introvert though it's very easy
for you to send a message you don't have
to have a conversation you know they're
not to bring them on the phone you can
just send them a hey I'm thinking about
you and I I know the things that you're
interested in and I just saw this and I
was thinking and one thing that I do a
lot of is if I read an article or I buy
a book that I'm interested in instead of
just broadcasting it on social for all
of my followers I will take that and
think about who that person who that
book would be for like what person in my
network would would like that book or if
I read that article who are the five
people I can send that article to that
would get something out of it because
when you post on social you're just
saying this is for everyone
versus here are some things that are
just for these individuals that I know
would get a kick out of it and are you
are you just going by memory yeah well I
mean I have like I'm
a little more detailed than that I have
sort of a journal okay of the
relationships and people that I keep up
with and I'm always kind of flipping
through that on a weekly basis so I'm a
little more organized than that but it
can also just be off the cup - well I
think it's important because I mean why
I ask that question of what is the most
important skill that the entrepreneur or
the habits that we're missing you said
this so for the people who aren't
naturally good at it having some kind of
system or structure that they can follow
so that it forces it because it's not
coming naturally you're top of mind no
it's not anyone oh but you're an
introvert you kind of want to avoid it
right and so if you you gotta you got to
plug it into your work stream and when
you keep those relationships up it's not
that you know why or how they're gonna
pay off but you just have to trust in
the magic of the universe they're
keeping these relationships up are
valuable I mean me being on your show we
probably had you know several different
time changes a lot of communication
about it and now I'm on your show
talking to you finally and if we never
talked again for two years that's sort
of a waste on both our sides right
because we we might have a relationship
for you know however long this Instagram
stream is but then it's then it's over
we never talk again so you know kind of
looking at it through that through that
lens so so reverse engineering that for
everybody watching if they have a
connection they they have a show they
just met somebody at a trade show or a
conference or they want to see in touch
what should I do after this so I'm gonna
I'm gonna open up Evernote or no pod and
say Jason Harris balloon dog yeah he
likes the gear jets you know and right
so some you know funky things and
whatever whatever our memories are from
this conversation write it down then
then you know I'm gonna move on with my
day and lots of other stuff what what is
the frequency you think that I should be
in touch with people I think you can be
in touch with which people maybe like
three or four times a year I mean it's
very men
it's not a weekly thing it's not a
monthly thing it's it's more of a
quarterly thing that you're you're
sending those notes out and then when I
hear from you and you send me something
I'm gonna be like oh yeah again I
remember being on that show I have a
guest who would be great on his show and
I'm gonna forward that to him as a
response right and so you know that's
that's relationship building
so everybody but at least once a quarter
but then I mean if I if I see that
Nemeth is coming to San Francisco for a
speaking event you know maybe I send it
your way yeah exactly right reach out to
okay yeah all right and he works really
well and a great story that I like to
tell which is I told that this just the
other day but I call it the million
dollar hoodie and I met a guy at a
conference who worked at Ben & Jerry's
and I thought he was a cool guy I got
his card and I sent him a mechanism
hoodie when I got back to the office and
it's like a warm hoodie as our mechanism
logo on it and I wasn't expecting
anything in return
I was just building a relationship with
him and sort of saying hi I thought he
was a cool guy and ten months later they
wanted to look for a new agency he wore
this hoodie that he put us in the mix to
pitch the business and we have won the
business we've had the business for five
years and I call that a million dollar
hoodie because just me being generous
and keeping that relationship going and
sending something to them without
expecting anything in return it's paid
off with one of our one of our great
clients and so I think that's sort of
the mindset not I'm gonna send this
hoodie and maybe I can get Ben and
Jerry's one day right you know I think
it's it's a different mindset of just
innately being generous without
expecting anything in return and if you
do that you're gonna get things back
with compound interest and you don't
know when or how but it pays off now you
said earlier that you were not naturally
generous yeah that's correct
I'm curious I'm not I am NOT a match
a generous person why well I'm I'm a
kind person okay
and I treat every everyone equally in
the company there's no second-class
citizens we we all we all work together
and collaborate really well but I'm not
going about my I am now but I wasn't
always going about my day thinking of
what value I can add to those around me
beyond work I was thinking about work
and how we all work together to
accomplish something but I wasn't
naturally free with my time or giving
advice if someone wanted to come in and
talk to me I just was slammed and too
busy and didn't have time to meet with
them and I changed that to be more
generous of my time more generous with
my advice more generous with connections
hooking up with people with people that
I know because it will help that person
and the person that I'm connecting them
with and not expecting anything in
return I've had to learn that skill and
I've seen that payoff in business but I
didn't come from a standpoint of I'm
gonna connect everyone with all my
contacts I came from a standpoint of
these are my contacts and I'm gonna get
more contacts I wasn't a mean spirited
person like I said I'm kind by nature
but I wasn't necessarily a connector or
free with advice I was like I learned
this thing and this is the thing I know
I'm not going to share it with you but
by being generous of spirit it's really
helped build our business and that was a
learn a learned trait that I talked
about in the book I was not naturally
that way so you've got the four
quadrants the four philosophies and then
underneath the eleven underlying habits
how do we yeah each principle each
principle has three three or so habits
that you can learn to build to that
principle right yeah and so successes
habits and and here the eleven habits
that you see will make people successful
how did we go about making the shift in
a habit so using you as an example I
said well I wasn't that too generous but
I've become generous you changed the
habit you've had more successful result
how do you take somebody who's on one of
those eleven habits and they're not
doing well they're not naturally
inclined towards and making that shift
so one thing I did with shifting to
become a more
generous person is I just made made a
mental note and it didn't always work
but it did did get their overtime every
time I bought a book it started with
this every time I bought a book I would
bought that I liked I would buy a second
book and I would keep this stack of
books and when I found someone that I
had met along the way that I thought
would benefit from this book that I had
read and write I send it to him so it
started with something simple like that
like I'm always gonna buy two books and
then I always have one book to give away
so a simple practice like that becomes
you just soar like oh I always buy two
books now so it becomes habit over time
or if someone says hey I need your
advice
can we talk my first inclination would
be you know not now I'm busy
I had to shift that in practice to
whenever someone ever asked me for
advice I always say yes and here's three
possible times that I can do it so I it
shifts that I can't - I will
mentally and you just you know you don't
always get it like you start out I will
I will I will
yeah and then over time you just program
your mind to always say yes always buy
two books always look for opportunities
to to be generous and so there's those
are just like two examples of things you
can you can start to blend into your
daily thought process so I'm super
curious about the second one because the
first one makes sense it's already habit
you have buying a book and it's easy to
remember okay a second book I love it
for the second one if you're in the
middle of something you're working with
some big pitch you know you're you're up
against a deadline you got to get this
thing out today and then somebody walks
into your office and say hey Jason can
you help me with XYZ default reactions
to be like I gotta finish this thing
yeah you know um I'm slammed right so so
yeah I you know what you want to be
doing you want to be you want to
approach with grace and understanding
and compassion and empathy and and and
yeah and all the four things on your
quadrants but then how do you overcome
it in the moment we're all you're
thinking about is I got to get this
pitch done today yes so I mean this
might not be relatable
for everyone because we have a
200-person company now and I have a an
EA so it's easy for me now but I'm just
gonna tell you in practice I will always
say yes my my first response is always
yes but I can't right now
schedule time with Nina and Nina knows
that when everyone everyone's gonna get
their there time for me to help them or
give them counsel if you don't have a
Nina and you don't have any yay you
still have to just always say yes but
you know I'll say I'll follow up with
sometimes or yes but send me three times
and I'll pick one so it's just it's
harder but instead of saying no just say
yes but here's what I can do it and I
would just say no I'm slammed and ignore
them and you know they'd be bummed and I
wouldn't follow up with them but now I'd
say of course here's here's a path but I
can't tonight so my wife now works with
me she I've got 20 people on my team but
oh god it's actually great it's it's I
really like the wife is Nina too but her
name is Nina so let me know when you're
talking Nina it's like I'm already
seeing my wife here I actually really
like it the the only issue we have in
working is if I'm focused and working on
something like if I'm if I'm trying to
find out when joe namath is going to San
Francisco and like I got to get this
thing off to Jason yeah you know today
and then she comes in and interrupts me
with something that is important to her
still related to the business I'll say
yes but it what the look on my face is
not yes oh okay right and that's what
I'm trying to avoid so our solution has
been anytime she interrupts me will
actually do a state ship that and we'll
just will will hug for like five seconds
just this is a state shift but I still
even though I know that's how I want to
act and I want to be kind and generous
and say yes of course how can I help my
default reaction is still are you
kidding me in my head I don't say that
out loud but but it shows on my face
right so
I'm trying to fix that so I was curious
your experience well you know I'm not a
face talker
so I don't know I don't know how you
know if you're one of those people you
wear your emotions on your sleeve and
I'm not I don't know if the hug thing
works but it sounds like it does I think
I think it's you're probably going to
have that scrunched up face for a period
of time until it becomes a part of you
and a habit where you're always saying
yes and over time that that face is
going to be less scrunched and less
scrunched in let's crunch but it's gonna
be yes just interrupt me I love it I
think that's too much to put on yourself
okay to change a practice of being
annoyed and saying no to saying yes and
not and then trying to change your
physical reaction I think that is just
gonna have to happen over time I mean
that's like that's almost too much to
take in at once I think all right
especially if you're a person and again
going back to leaning into who you are
as a person and being yourself
wearing your emotions on your sleeve can
be a really powerful thing and people
always know where you stand and there's
no guesswork you're not hiding you're
not acting so I wouldn't I wouldn't
worry about changing that too much
because that's who you are you know
that's your innate that makes you you
alright more patience it's slowly
getting better more patience I
appreciate it well no I'm a name I'm an
impatient person but you're right
entrepreneur I'm a real real cool well
the book is the soulful art of
persuasion
where are they going Jason if they want
to pick it up
it's sold in Barnes Noble everywhere in
store and yeah I think I think your view
your audience will really get a lot out
of it it's a fun fast read there's a lot
of psychology and research and pop
cultural antidotes in there some
advertising stories some personal
stories but it's a very fun informative
quick read cool and for the YouTube
audience we'll link that up in the
description and below you can go check
it out
Jason appreciate you man takes was
taking the time
thank you it was really fun all right
much love I'm gonna send you something
every quarter I'm waiting on my stage I
love it thank you man if you want to see
my interview with tom bill you check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
what are you doing you're not answering
the question I'm asking
I felt so hopeless and so lost and just
unsure of how it's gonna make anything
in my life